all right ross is out on assignment
today but with me at the desk is someone
that i stalk on instagram
and he decided to actually come here and
do the show with me please welcome the
esteemed editor-in-chief of people
magazine dan wakeford
i'm so relieved i haven't scared you
away i'm always commenting on your
inspiration
i'm in real life too but it means so
much you said it's your favorite
magazine you've been on the cover 13
times trick 13 times folks you also have
great book reviews movie reviews what to
watch i'm like on the feeder always of
your shopping list i mean water watch
has been so important the last two years
because we've watched more television
and movies than ever before i know it's
so true in fact you picked up peacemaker
as what to watch
and mr john cena is coming on so that
was serendipitous um you are a newsmaker
would you um be so
kind to get into some headlines with me
i would love to do sorry i'm hitting the
half life of dan rayford i cannot
believe this oh right
so today our nation celebrates the life
and work of dr martin luther king jr he
will forever inspire
leadership his compassion and his total
commitment to unity and non-violence as
the way to equality and we're kicking
off the headlines with the historic news
about one of dr king's collaborators
maya angelou
i love this story so much this is
exactly what we're talking about to try
and bring you news that is so
life-affirming cnn reports that the
legendary american poet is officially
the first black woman to be featured on
the u.s corridor
[Applause]
i know why the caged bird sings and it's
the first of 20 quarters dedicated to
incredible women in american history dan
thoughts
long last show them the money
this is very exciting i mean it's such a
good group of women that they've chosen
and i love the fact that they've chosen
women in the arts as well there's also
anime wong who's a seminal asian actress
who is these are unhung sung heroes have
also been highlighted well you know what
when someone like maya angelou shows up
on a quarter it makes it seem worthwhile
to me
next we're going to talk about another
phenomenal woman showrunner
extraordinaire
shonda rhimes another woman who i could
see
leading the pack
every time she sneezes and creates
another great hit scandal how to get
away with murder grey's anatomy now
going into its eighteenth season not to
mention bridgerton come on he started on
netflix and showed everybody what time
it is with her very first show becoming
the most successful
show that they have had thus far i think
squid game might have beaten it
just
but i really love this because she told
people
that she may be a powerhouse but there's
one title that she fully rejects and
it's girl boss she says it's total bs
she doesn't like throwing a bunch of
women into a cheap catch phrase and she
argues don't do this men don't have to
deal with it um
and
it's so true it's like there's no like
boy boss like dan what do you think of
that sort of attitudinal you gotta be
this to be successful i mean i
understand where it came from it came
from women's empowerment and after
spending time with my little nieces over
the holidays i understand sometimes
girls don't realize that they can be
anything and so the idea of like telling
them they can be a boss the sentiment's
there but really this phrase has reached
its shelf life we don't need to qualify
women that you can be a boss and and i i
agree with shonda i do too i remember
like i someone wanted to do like this
badass thing with me and i was like i
don't i just i feel
um
it's just not the right again it's tone
for me
and i don't need sassy and crass to
prove my capacities
and believe me i'm naughty
so it's not like i'm looking for it to
be squeaky clean
but i don't need to plant a
flag in the sand i would rather be kind
and i would rather be funny and find a
way to combine all of those tones that
don't have like cruelty or craftsness
you know may she be all of our north
star in behavior
oh for sure okay dan your story
well next
the next story counts is a bit of a bad
news for me apparently since i've made a
career out of pop culture and
celebrities a new research study claims
people obsessed with hollywood and
celebs are not very smart
how do they determine this researchers
in hungary asked two thousand adults
only 2 000 to take a set of vocabulary
and math tests then they quizzed them on
their level of interest in celebrities
those who scored high on celebrity
interest scored low in cognitive ability
i mean well then
i mean i reject this whole philosophy
i'm a big believer in the higher your iq
your greater the need for celebrity news
i have met lawyers i have met wall
street bankers who are obsessed with
celebrities i think being interested in
celebrity news means you're interested
in people you're interested in life
you're interested in learning and i
think there's a lot of benefits there
obviously scholars gossip can be very
negative but celebrity news can be
positive reading about you and your
story is very inspiring drew and
learning things and takeaways from
different people's lives
celebrities are just celebrity stories
they're just modern day shakespeare it's
to entertain us it's our moment of
self-care and a busy day to read and
escape from our difficult life so i
think there's a lot of benefits this
this study is just trying to make people
feel bad about themselves celebrity
stories and any stories are a way of
escaping your life and making yourself
happy and learning things i think also a
lot of people especially again in a
people magazine will talk about their
struggles and their triumphs and the
road of the journey which can be very
educational very i say
but i do like the study it is
fascinating it is but only 2 000
hungarians that that's not a big study
like
i'm hungarian and i say no
um well finally it's freezing outside
which means it's officially noodle
slurping season and we've got some food
news
oh dan this is scary well i don't know
are you a carb fan i
try and avoid them after six
oh it's well it's not six yet okay so
these aren't any old nudes they're from
the incredible chef david chang one of
my very favorite chefs on planet earth
and one of the biggest innovators in the
food industry he's the man behind the
mamafuco food group and he's teamed up
with asha noodles to create mama fuco
instant noodles they come in three
flavors and they take four minutes to
cook they're air dried and not fried and
that means 25 less calories than other
instant noodles double the protein add
the zero you get better cholesterol and
they're selling like hot cakes by the
way i'm salivating as i'm talking about
this i'm not kidding and this is our
first official taste danny oh sorry i
tasted it already um this is dangerous
like special date night and now you can
get it at home and then i can eat these
carbs at home this is this is going to
be a dangerous year oh my gosh they're
so good ooh they've got a fantastic
little kick
they're not too salty
they've got a great texture that holds a
little al dente they're not mushy at all
oh my gosh they've
thank you once again to david chang
for being such an innovator
and i just love these
[Music]
you